first up here's the best-selling author
of Moneyball the blindside the big short
whose new book is the fifth risk he also
hosts the against the rules podcast
Michael Lewis ok so once again you've
done it you you have written a book I
think that is very important and I think
it could be subtitled hooray for the
deep state or hooray for bureaucrats and
I think Trump always says he's a
different kind of Republican but what
the consistency with other Republicans
is always funneling money to the rich
people and also all the way back to
Reagan who said government is the
problem
yeah and problem government has never
had a publicist to stand up and say hey
wait a second we're not the problem this
is us this is the deep state the
bureaucrats this is what we do this is
how we make your life better I think
that's what your book is trying to do
this is absolutely true the government
is funny way the opposite of Trump Trump
has this unbelievable ability to take
credit for all these things he never did
right and the government is doing all
these incredible things that has no
ability or instinct or inclination to
sell itself but you know trumpet he's a
departure in in some ways from
Republicans because up until this point
I mean the thing that caught my
attention was when he at the moment he's
elected he is he was by the law required
to build a transition team hundreds of
people who were supposed to go into the
government until law the day it's a it's
a law yes and and so Hillary Clinton had
built one too and the Obama
administration by law had said just add
a thousand people for six months
preparing briefings every which way and
these are not ideological things it sort
of like how the place works like we
dealt with the Ebola virus this is how
we did right and no business works this
way where every four or eight no no it's
you have to pass on the all the
infrastructure and how the operation
works to a new group people don't really
agree with the absolute of the most
critical right tuition on the face of
the planet right so you have so the so
the you're supposed to come in the day
after the election they're waiting for
them in in conference rooms that the
Department of Commerce and the
Department of the Treasury and so on is
over little thing
your sandwiches set out and parking spot
set aside expecting this wave of Trump
people to come in and take the
government over underst
and no one shows up no one shows up
Trump fire has fired the entire
operation right and said to Chris
Christie who would dissemble the
operation that we don't need that you
and I can spend two hours at the victory
party we'll know everything we need to
know about how to run the government
yeah now this is the beginning of a most
the most in Crimea Mother Republicans I
mean Obama was grateful for the way Bush
had handed over the government it's not
that different in that it started with
Reagan this idea that government is bad
they are the problem this is true and
that we would be better with less and
less government so the idea that he's
gutting the government and he is that
goes back a long way and people think
it's a good thing and again they don't
have someone to stand up I wish everyone
would read this book this is absolutely
earthier yeah and my question is how you
know this is the deep said how much
gutting can go on how deep is your state
I really want to know you know no it is
it is a measure of how ignorant the
American people now are of their
government if they they can be sold the
idea that such a thing is the deep state
it's insane I mean you know I didn't
have any particular predisposition or a
pre-existing idea who is gonna find when
I started wandering around the
government but they are the most
extraordinary people who are still there
doing the work and the work is that
important and that so bit Trump so right
Reagan makes Trump possible the whole
this whole sales job that the government
isn't important or the government's the
problem enables him to neglect it and
they're their own worst enemy in a way
cuz they're so modest
they don't brag about it they don't let
you know they're so unsung that they
don't even name the department's I
learned a lot of this in your book with
the name that applies to them so we
don't know what they do the Department
of Energy yeah no that's a great guards
the nukes right the Department of
Agriculture I even I thought mostly what
they do is with farmers but they do a
million other things a huge budget 164
billion dollars most of it not to do
with farmers here's the drummer says is
nothing to do with Commerce you can't
even get the friggin name right
drinking game at the Department of
Agriculture and and the drinking game is
guess if the Agriculture Department does
it and if you guess wrong you have to
drink because there's almost nothing it
doesn't do what does it do well I mean
on an airliner on a truck they have
their own Air Force is a 250 billion
dollar bank inside the place right have
far a responsibility food stamps keeping
geese off runways you know you know
there's a there isn't real Sulli about
that well that's right but I mean the
department of agriculture employs run
around with shotguns and fireworks at
all the airports America make sure that
a geese doesn't a goose doesn't fly into
them but I mean and the people and took
over these departments are people who I
mean the the performance art to me is
Rick Perry you know ran in 20 that's
humble mean that's that's trolling you
know ran on I don't know what air it's
such low-hanging fruit don't know what
this department is or what it does and
now you're the Secretary of it says he
wants to get rid of it right he says he
want to get rid of and can't remember
its name and then finds out it's the
Department of nuclear right it's a
nuclear weapon yes right yeah the
nuclear weapons and this all this basic
scientific research that won't get done
by industry that will secure our energy
future no he is no it's it's so obvious
that the people who roll in with Trump
are are not only the Rick Rick Perry's
in a funny way of the benign in defense
right because he's not really a grifter
right a lot of them are in for the money
the Wilbur Ross's I mean Trump we saw
this this week with ten years of
basically doing that thing where he
would pretend to be a corporate raider
say I'm gonna buy the Vatican and Exxon
and merge them and then the stock price
would go up and he wouldn't do it but he
collected and then he'd sell its no and
no one has said I don't understand about
this is essentially a pump and dump
scheme yep I'm amazed that the SEC is
not all over this I feel like he's doing
it now with China if he tweets anything
about his deals with China
he calls billionaires at night that's
probably what he's telling her you know
it's your big report you know your
bigger point that who should so who
shows up when you've got a president who
really does not care about the federal
government doesn't he doesn't actually
have the way
to be thinking I'm gonna dismantle the
federal girl and that's always thinking
he's thinking I care about myself
there's this thing I'm supposed to be
running but no one will notice if I
don't and and and but so who shows up in
that it's if people show up or not
people who are attracted to the mission
because the missions have been abandoned
the money money so you find the most
extraordinary cases of people who's the
guy now who he wants to run the oceanic
this is unbelie-- what's that department
called it National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration is Saturday
the weather right okay the Weather
Service the Weather Service which is one
of the most spectacular stories fill
with people we've got you've talked
about great public servants oh you know
all these people why don't you go to
work for the weather Weather Service you
why are you obsessed with the weather to
the extent you go and do this as opposed
to go make money in the private sector
it's all these people who were
traumatized as children by some storm
that they all have that story like like
the hail broke my window Wow and
thousand Dorothy Gale and they've done
yes and what they've done is
unbelievable it's one of the great
untold stories in intellectual history
they have improved the weather forecasts
so 10 years ago your your your your your
fifth day forecast today is as good as
your tip your your your one day was 10
years ago your heart can forecast I grew
up in New Orleans and we used to see you
know right you'd figure out whether
hurricane was coming by going out
throwing a frisbee you know that nobody
could tell you whether thing was gonna
show up or how big it was gonna be and
now you have all these I'll elaborate
warnings thanks to them so who does he
wants to he wants a cue was the CEO of
AccuWeather which is the private yeah
they're in the business of essentially
repackaging the National Weather Service
and he has been on it the guys name is
Barry Meyers has been on a 20-year
campaign to prevent The Weather Service
from communicating with the American
people unless he could do it in my yeah
so he can do it for money unless unless
lives or he's gonna be the Fox now to
guard that him yeah it's the same story
all over the government but it's it's
sort of like there is a really nice good
well private sector weather so all those
people in the private sector say he is
the worst guy among us to put in there
of all of us don't bully and so this has
happened oh you don't believe global
warming is real but they think the
weather's girls tits are real it's a
great book here what's always our
Michael over glad we got you on the show
you